what up space fam goals in here from
anime opera and i'm back at it again to
discuss how strong another demonstrator
character is exactly and this time we're
focusing on gootaro the stronger part of
upper moon 6. last time i discussed daki
and said i'd make this one if that one
got over 7 000 likes and as of right now
that one has over 12 000 likes so it's
about time to do this one and i'm hoping
to more or less release this around the
time utaro is introduced in the new
season so hopefully i got close if you
do enjoy these videos and want to keep
them coming channel demonstrate within
and smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing that like button is
hashira energy and passing is muzon
energy so choose wisely i'm also not
sure what i should cover next so leave a
suggestion of the video topic you want
to see in the comments if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and this
is crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demonstrator videos and
updates while you wait for the next
video to drop feel free to check out my
growing playlist that includes videos on
all the hashira demon moons and much
more linked to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all now
this will all make more sense if you
already watched the donkey video link in
the description because in this one
we're skipping over doki's initial fight
and jumping to gyutaro's debut right
after tangent embarrasses daki badly by
cutting off her head as if it was just
an afterthought daki has been built up
to this point because of how well she
did against tundra but also because she
acted like she was excited to see a
hashira and as we'll get into later it's
implied that she killed multiple hashira
in the story so that sounds pretty op
clearly this generation of hasha is
special though since for tangent she's
too weak for him to even consider her an
upper moon he sliced off her head before
she even knew what was happening she
doesn't die though because she's just a
part of upper moon 6 and her neck
actually has to be cut at the same time
as guterres for them both to die anyways
while doki is crying and insisting that
she's really strong despite what tengen
says yutaro comes out of her body tengen
immediately gets way more serious than
he just was clearly sensing the
difference in power between yutarandaki
he tries to quickly cut gutaro but the
upper moon is too quick youtuber not
only dodges but takes daki to safety and
is trying to cheer her up while
completely ignoring our sound hashira
clearly he doesn't feel threatened at
all gyutaro then attacks tengen and he's
so fast that tangent has to use his
forehead protector to block the attack
gyutero compliments tengen saying i was
really trying to kill you you're good
yeah definitely good end quote it
clearly sounds like a compliment and it
is a compliment in a way but he doesn't
look worried at all he's clearly being
patronizing and now tangent knows he'll
have a difficult fight ahead of him in
certain contrast to how easily he beat
doki we also see at this point that
gyutaro's weapons of choice are two
boney looking sickles we later find out
that upper moon wine can create a sword
using his flesh and that's the case with
these sickles too gyutar just creates
them from his own flesh after promising
to avenge daki for what they did to her
and explaining that he's jealous of
tengen's good looks and height kyoto
attacks he can throw his sickles and
they spin around and fly back as tundra
notices tangent succeeds in not only
surviving but saving innocent people too
and you gotta love tengen he taunts the
jealous cutero even more by saying he
has not one but three wives and much
like zanitsu yutoro says that's too much
and he can't forgive that we then see
the other aspect of gyutaro's blood
demon art not only can he throw the
sickles and have them come back he can
also use them or just parts of his body
to create countless flying blades of
blood tengan realizes this move is opie
and he can block all the blades while
protecting the others but in his flashy
way he finds a potential solution which
includes creating an explosion that
drops them down to the floor below it's
quick thinking in a great move that
perfectly embodies tengen's style
however unfortunately for him yutaro can
even control the blood blades and makes
them turn so that tangent has to try
destroying them yutaro is one of the
trickiest demons and his blood demon art
embodies that he can create countless
airborne blood blades already op then he
can control them and furthermore as we
find out if even one hits you which is
almost guaranteed it starts poisoning
you making you weaker and weaker over
the course of the battle while demons
like yutaro don't really get exhausted
up until now tegano is protecting people
but he hears that they fled by now and
so we can see how gyutaro can do against
an undistracted hashira tengen's
explosions don't seem to be that
effective against the two demons and now
the two demons are going to fight as one
as they say and since they are tied
together in a sense you could try to
consider daki as a tool at kyoto's
disposal although she can also be seen
as a hindrance as we'll discuss later
still i think the fact that she needs to
have her head cut for gyutara to die
makes him a lot harder to kill and there
are even more benefits that he gets from
working with her as we'll see duterte
goes on to say that tangent is different
from the other hashira gyutaro has
killed he thinks that tangent is special
and blessed with talent but tengen
laughs in his face he implies that they
must have encountered some pretty weak
hashira if they think he's talented
since there are way more talented hashra
than him stonehashira gyomei miss
tashramuichiro and flame hasha and goku
specifically cross his mind and this
goes with what i've been saying i think
this is an especially talented
generation since if you watch my hashtag
rank from week is the strongest video
you know i placed tangent near the
bottom of this generation and yet yutaro
thinks he's exceptional based on his
past run-ins with hashira anyways
gootaro reveals the whole bloodsicles
are poisonous thing and wonders why the
effects aren't kicking in to which
tengen replies that he's from a ninja
family and he's built up a resistance to
poison now resistance is not immunity so
he'll still be affected eventually but
it's important to note that a lot of
other fighters who had no resistance to
poison would be much worse off at this
point that should be noted when
considering how strong yutara is since
tangent is kind of a natural good
opponent to fight him still as mentioned
it does start to show although it
spreads slower than it would for most
people youtu is happy to see the poison
has an effect saying that tengan's stoic
attitude almost bluffed him into
thinking that it had no effect at all
the fight continues and despite tengen's
cool tricks like being able to use
explosives with enough force to hurt
demons and being able to extend one
blade's reach by holding the other by
the tip he doesn't have much success
against kyotaro even the extended reach
which is a clever trick that with
tangent speed could probably allow him
to cut off the head of many an
unsuspecting demon does not work against
gyutero who just appears to effortlessly
block the attack to tangan's credit
though he does manage to slice off
donkey's head again to the point where
her losing her head almost becomes an
ongoing joke during this battle
nevertheless kyutaro notes that bit by
bit they are gradually getting closer to
winning against tangent and considering
the fact that gyutaro doesn't even
appear to have broken a sweat yet
figuratively speaking that's very
impressive and this makes sense since
tengen is not only suffering from normal
human exhaustion but the more serious
effects of poisoning as well luckily at
this point zanitsu and inosuke joined
the party followed by tanjiro too
tanjuro who often can smell the strength
of his opponent notably immediately
senses that yutaro is the core one and
smells different the impact of his scent
makes tanjiro's throat numb his hand is
also shaking and he's not sure if it's
exhaustion or his fear of gyutero since
this is tanjun or nazanitsu a statement
like that is saying a lot it's at this
point yutaro says many demon slayers
have died trying to accomplish the easy
task of beating him including some
hashira he says that i quote i've eaten
15 of you and my sister seven more end
quote now other sources like the
demonstrator wiki say he at least ate 13
hashira but there's no link to the
original source whether it was an
earlier translation of this part another
part of the manga or a data book fact
let me know if you got the direct
citation and source in the comments
however what he's saying here in the
official viz translation can be read in
different ways it suggests that he could
have eaten 15 hashira or perhaps he
means just 15 demon slayers in general
when he says 15 of you i do think 15
hashtag would be a safe bet since he was
obviously going to beat tangen before
the others show up and as he mentioned
tangent was stronger than the others
still if someone does have the direct
citation and source for the at least 13
hashira figure floating around the
internet let me know in the comments the
anime should also help clear up this
specific point and number soon but
specifics aside he's clearly strong
enough to take out hashira and usually
without much trouble anyways tengen has
help here too so he's not so easy to
overcome zainto and nosuke break off to
fight daki while tundra and tangent
focus on gyutaro it's at this point that
we see geytoro's final form if you will
he closes one of his eyes and opens
another eye on daki's forehead which he
can see through we'll get into the
specifics in a bit of how this works but
immediately you can imagine that at the
very least this increases guterres
vision of the battlefield and gives him
two perspectives of what's going on
rather than just one back to the fight
tantra smells such powerful evil that
goosebumps appear all over his body he
decides he needs to protect the poison
tangent and will swing his sword the
moment utara moves even the tiniest bit
and then we see a giant flex from
gyutaro where even though tundra was so
cautious giutero closes the distance and
appears in front of tundra with his
sickle pointed right at our
protagonist's neck whether it was from
just relative slowness compared to
gyutara fear causing paralysis or both
tundra could not dodge on his own and
would have died right there if tengen
didn't pull him out of the way at this
point it's clear that if tundra faced
yutaro alone at first instead of daki
tundra would have already been dead by
now and couldn't continue to grow
throughout the battle as he will do
tangent for now at least can keep up
with gyutaro's speed in the meantime
doki is confronting zainto and inosuke
saying with guterre awake now she can
use her full strength gyotoro isn't just
stronger than daki he makes her stronger
too and he even laughs at tengen saying
these demon series aren't nearly as
strong as tangent was suggesting he says
they don't have tsuguko or hashira
successor capabilities for now at least
yutaro is so confident in his power that
he views what he's seen and sensed from
tundra zainsoninosuke so far as being
laughably weak it doesn't take long for
gutaro to get the advantage against
tengen as he's fighting tengen from the
front some blood blades fly in from
tengen's back to cut him down even
tengen thinks there's no escape and that
could have been it but tundra comes into
the rescue and blocks the bloodsicles
with his own sword so not only was
tengen almost defeated right there the
block wasn't even easy for tanjiro as he
states these attacks are slowing him
down he needs to dodge and deflect
because the direct blow would snap his
sword that's how strong the flying blood
blades are thus he switches over to
water breathing for defense because it
is better at deflecting attacks and he
knows that head on yootara will always
be stronger than him another thing to
keep in mind is daki's sashes are
attacking them along with gyutaro and
his blood blades making it all the more
difficult for them to avoid or block all
the attacks and even non-lethal wounds
will poison and eventually slow them
down if not kill them tangent sees
tundra is in bad shape and realizes that
if he doesn't finish this fast all the
demon slayers will die in the meantime
we joined daki vs zainsoninosuke and
there too they have to avoid sashes and
blood blades inosuke's sense of touch
senses that the blood blades are
especially dangerous and that even a
slight nick would be enough to kill him
all our guys are clearly losing while
tanjiro can barely breathe while
avoiding the ferocious attacks but then
one of tengen's wives appears with what
i can only describe as a multi-shuriken
launcher she launches them all and
thanks to that and the fact that the
shuriken are coated in wisteria extract
aka demon poison tengen cuts gutaro's
legs and they fail to regenerate
immediately because of the poison his
body goes numb enough poison was used to
paralyze a normal demon for half a day
and to even immobilize a lower moon but
the question is how well and long will
it work on yutaro tangent and tundra
immediately move to cut off the head but
it's no use scutaro as an upper moon
recovers completely in a few seconds or
less he launches flying sickles from his
stationary arms and tangent has to kick
tundra to safety before giving it his
all to block the blood blades with his
own attacks then in a split second gutar
shows off his speed by appearing before
tengen's wife on the roof and grabbing
her the sashes are keeping tengen from
coming to the rescue but luckily tanjiro
was underestimated manages to use a
combination of water and hirokami kagura
to save hinatsuru the wife in question
yutaro is surprised by seeing such a
fast maneuver since he assumed tundra
shouldn't be that speedy anymore gyutaro
goes to attack tanjiro but tangent
appears at this moment and they launch a
collective attack at utero's neck only
to have the upper moon block all three
blades one of tundras and both of
tangans yutaro launches another vortex
of bloodsickles and tanjiro and the wife
are saved because tangent pushes off the
roof and takes yutara with him and even
though guterres is fighting tangent
ahashira as tundra notices gyutara takes
a swipe at our protagonist too with his
blood blades and it's also a close call
he's clearly got energy and
concentration to spare despite the fact
that he's fighting and even winning
against tengen it's around this point
that inosuke asks tanjiro for help
against daki showing that he and zains
were having considerable trouble against
the weaker part of upper moon 6. tanjo
does stay to help them for a while and
together they end up taking doki's head
off inosuke is specifically the one that
ends up cutting it off because his
chipped dual blades are perfect for the
task then he takes like a football in
his arms and starts running with it so
she can't reattach it at this point
we're wondering what's going on with
tangent and gyutaro is tengan holding
his own against him without tundra's
help and the answer is no he wasn't able
to hold him off on his own guterres
suddenly appears and stabs inosuke with
his poison covered sickle it appears
like he stabbed him in the heart and
that would have been the case with
anyone else but as we later figure out
inosuke can shift his internal organs
and by doing so he avoided a lethal
wound it's at this point that we see
something else that's really scary
tundra spots a bloody tangent on the
ground seemingly lifeless and he even
has one of his arms detached cut off it
looks like yutaro killed him then tundra
wakes up after one of youture's attacks
to find that inosuke zenitsu and tangen
all look like they're finished gyutero
even calls tundra lucky for surviving
the previous attack and fall youtube
goes on to say that tangent a hashira
was weak all he had going for him was
determination but the poison got him his
heart stopped according to gyotaro and
so the upper moon understandably assumes
he's dead guitar calls them all pathetic
at this point tundra notices that
gyutero could kill him and that tundra's
arm is numb and he couldn't hurt the
upper moon even if he tried it's another
chance that gyotor had to finish off
tanjuro but instead of doing it he
questions him about his sister and
enjoys insulting him for failing to
protect his sister as the older brother
instead of going in for the kill he
tortures tanjiro by breaking the fingers
on his hand yootaro tries to convince
tanjo to become a demon but then tenjo
uses his signature and legendary
headbutt to shogutaro what he thinks of
that idea youtu is more affected by the
headbutt than he expected and he
realizes it's because tundra stabbed him
with one of the poison kunais at the
same time that he headbutted him credit
needs to be given to tundra for strategy
here because he even clawed open a
perfume bag to hide the smell of the
poison so that gutero would be caught
off guard yutaro's big mistake here was
wanting to break tundra's spirit before
killing him but he failed to do this and
it allowed tundra this opportunity
tundra takes his sword with his broken
fingers and all and goes to slice off to
temporarily paralyze guterre's head daki
is about to help her brother but then
zenitsu appears from the rubble using a
new op version of thunderclap called
godspeed that surprises daki with how
fast it is however tundra cannot cut
through the neck and pretty soon yutara
starts releasing blood blades from his
body again tundra refuses to give up
even when gyutaro completely recovers
and goes for a fatal attack it is at
this moment when tundra is saved yet
again by tengen who is missing an arm
and is looking very poisoned but is
still fighting on it turns out tangent
forced his own heart to stop to keep the
blood from circulating and probably to
surprise guterre later he also explains
how he perfected his musical score
technique where he converts the rhythm
of the enemy's attacks into sound so
every fight becomes a song he hears
repeated phrases and can attack between
beats and during the rests dancing with
his opponent this ability takes time but
when it clicks against a particular
opponent he's much more effective the
only problem is he's very poisoned by
now so despite being able to read
yutaro's moves the best he can do is
block his attacks he can't go in for the
neck that will have to be tanjiro yutero
goes on to cut one of tengen's eyes but
tangent keeps going tundra goes to
attack and guterro sticks a sickle
straight into his neck it's at this
point we're told exactly what the
purpose of the third eye on daki's
forehead is the narrator tells us that
the thing that was giving tundra and the
others trouble was the fact that gyutero
could fight while controlling his sister
too he saw what she saw giving him two
points of view on what was happening he
never let on he was able to do this and
it just made him seem more powerful so i
don't think he was choosing to control
her the whole time because he does later
insult daki for not doing a better job
but it is noteworthy that he could
control her when he wanted to he could
thus control himself the blood blades
donkey and probably her sashes while
having multiple perspectives on the
battlefield it's truly insane to think
about and then you throw in the poison
that should be slowing down his
opponents the whole time but our guys
just don't quit to guterro's shock they
keep getting back up despite being
severely overpowered to quote the manga
as time went on they got used to it and
began to adapt and even with a sickle in
his throat and coming out of his mouth
tundra keeps going he tries to swing at
yutaru's neck one more time he tells
himself to summon 100 times the strength
of a single blow his eyes turn
completely white and his mark evolves to
look more like the mark of yorichi the
strongest demon slayer in history and
first sun breather who traumatized muzan
centuries ago in this form tendril
succeeds in cutting off yootaro's head
even so gyutar would usually be fine
because daki's head has to be cut off at
the same time but unfortunately for him
inosuke joins zanitsu and together they
slice off her neck too finally it looks
like our guys won but as a goodbye gift
youturo's body releases some more
dangerous vortexes of blood blades more
than ever before in a final attempt to
kill tanjiru fortunately for tundra
nezuko was well enough to save him and
was even able to save him from the
poisoning using her blood demon art
which burns demons and also uterus
poison from the human body she goes on
to help inosuke and tangent 2 with the
poison it's safe to say that if not for
nezuko tundra probably nosuke and
definitely tangent would have died from
the poisoning tundra goes on to find the
disappearing heads of yutarandaki
arguing they are blaming each other for
the loss and as mentioned daki says
gyutaro should have controlled her so
she finished the hashra instead of
expecting her to do it on her own so
clearly he wasn't controlling her the
whole time whether gyota or not taking
over doki was because of his trust in
her because of underestimating his
opponents or because he was too
distracted with tundra and tangent is up
for debate but the ability to take over
another person while fighting yourself
is a crazy option to have in the
backstory we find out that guitar even
as a human was good at fighting so he
worked as a debt collector he beat up
his marks whether they paid or not and
even his bosses couldn't keep him in
line he was even skilled enough as a
human to kill a samurai after the
samurai took a cheap shot and sliced him
from behind yutaro carrying his dying
sister who was previously burned for
taking the samurai's eye runs into upper
moon 2 doma it's not surprising that
when doma offers to save their lives by
turning them into demons yuto agrees if
it means saving and protecting his
sister he doesn't even have to think
about it and then as we know his
existing fighting skills get enhanced by
his demon transformation and blood demon
art and he eventually becomes upper moon
6 along with daki who he's able to use
as a tool in any battle it's actually a
really good backstory and you can really
sympathize with pre-demon gyutaro since
all he had was a sister he lived and
worked for her and they burned her when
he was away and had no shot of even
trying to protect her now let's get into
the aftermath after the guterro battle
tangent retires with his three wives a
detail i like and he definitely deserved
to and of course even if he didn't
retire he would be less strong with one
arm and eye since this isn't one piece
so you could say that gyutaro took this
hasha out of commission as well along
with the other ones he killed when igoro
is saying tengen can't retire because
there is no one of tengen's caliber even
wounded who can replace him tengen
replies that there is someone who has
grown strong enough and he refers to
tanjiro so in tengen's view at least
tundra is strong enough to replace him
which seems to imply that tanjiro is
hashera level already i say this because
it illustrates upper moon 6's strength
it shows just how skilled the characters
who barely ended up defeating yutaru and
daki actually were at this point between
tanjura tang and his wives nezuko
inosuke and zenitsu you could
comfortably say that together they're
represented more than the power of two
hashira when they fight guter and daki
now some hashra are a lot stronger than
others but i'm talking about the minimum
level involved to become a hashera here
which is still an impressive level of
power the demons here core master is
ecstatic when he hears that they went
against an upper moon and says the
balance that hasn't shifted for a
hundred years has just tipped later
muzon meets with the remaining upper
moons and tells him that guterre died
muslin actually says he expected yutara
would lose as he thought daki was a
hindrance he points out that if yutaro
had fought by himself from the beginning
he would have won he also mentions that
he shouldn't have fought after poisoning
them but that it doesn't matter anymore
this last part doesn't make much sense
to me since nezuko could have just saved
them from the poisoning anyways if
yutara ran away after poisoning them but
the earlier part is interesting as
mentioned before if yuta initially
fought tundra 101 tundra would have been
dead and couldn't grow over the course
of the fight enough to eventually cut
off his head this is very true and
throughout the fight i mentioned times
where gyotaro could have won if not for
this or that or the other thing
including the time he decided to torment
and anger tanjuro instead of just
quickly finishing him off this is how
upper moon fights usually go everything
goes perfectly so that our side barely
comes out with the win and it's
satisfying because they win while the
mangaka also gets to illustrate just how
strong and overpowering the demons are
if we start looking ahead in the story
then obviously utaru is not that strong
by comparison to the stronger upper
moons and to how strong tundra
eventually gets but at this point in the
story he proved to be very very strong
he and daki killed hashra in the past
they would have wrecked tangent if it
wasn't for all of the help from the
others and even with that help tengen
still sent himself into retirement
afterwards citing not being able to
fight with the wounds he received as a
reason if anything went differently like
if nezuko couldn't expel guterre's
poison if hinosuke couldn't shift his
organs in impossible ways if yutara
fought tundra instead of daki at first
if zainitori nosuke weren't there to
occupy daki if tangen couldn't stop his
heart if tundra didn't evolve his
demonstrator mark to look more like
yorichi's and go beast mode and so on
the results would have been different
and way more tragic they have to spend a
lot of time recovering after this fight
and tanjo and inosuke's post-fight
conditions greatly worry kano and ali so
yeah gyutar was strong and offered a
great first victory against an upper
moon he could use blood blades that he
could control midair or just release
from his body in all directions like a
bomb and one touch could deliver enough
poison to eventually kill the opponent
on top of that he could control doki and
her sashes and both of their heads had
to be cut off at the same time for them
to be killed meaning it would be
virtually impossible for one character
no matter how strong to take them both
out if they stayed far away from one
another it was arrogance and
carelessness that got guten or killed
and arguably daki was a hindrance in
certain ways as mozam pointed out it's
easy to underrate yutaro and gloss over
him in videos about all the upper moons
but once you stop and analyze this arc
and all the details it becomes clear
that he was strong enough to give us one
insanely good and satisfying fight and
that is it for this video about how
strong upper moon 6 utara is if you do
enjoy these videos and want to keep them
coming channel the demonstrator within
and smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing that like button is
hashtag energy and passing is moves on
energy so choose wisely like i said i'm
not sure what topic i should cover next
so leave a suggestion of a video topic
you want to see in the comments when
you're burning up to see if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my growing playlist
that includes videos of the hashida all
the demon moons and much more videos
just like this one link to that is in
the description and until next time see
ya space cowboys